all eyes are in Ada County Idaho where
jury selection for the trial of Doomsday
cult Mom Lori valo dabel is scheduled to
start on Monday valo is charged with
murder and conspiracy in the deaths of
her children J.J valo and Tyler Ryan
along with Tammy dabell the first wife
of her husband Chad dabell he's being
tried separately on similar charges valo
has been in jail for over three years
after the pandemic delayed proceedings
related to things like competency now in
a big topic expected to be brought up
during jury selection is religion you
see the prosecution says the murders
were tied to the con to the couple's
extremist beliefs but before jury
selection even begins three big
developments happened in the case that
you need to know about so first Chad
dabell Lori valo were supposed to be
tried together but now that now that is
not happening you see judge Stephen
Boyce ruled last year that the couple
would be tried together in Ada County
however defense attorneys brought up on
several occasions that dabell waved his
right to a speedy trial while valo did
not not Dave Bell's defense team argued
that their client's case would require
more prep time and that trying them
together would Rob them of that time in
March of this year the judge finally
agreed to sever their cases just a month
before the trial was set to begin now
the second big change valo no longer
faces the possibility of getting the
death penalty if she's convicted in May
of 2022 prosecutors announced that they
were going to seek the death penalty in
valo's case or if the defense team filed
a motion opposing that decision last
month citing Discovery violations mental
health concerns and media attention the
motion even said quote we don't kill
witches anymore in America judge Boyce
ultimately ruled in favor of the defense
and the maximum sentence that valo can
now face is life in prison without the
possibility of parole but there's
something else that you need to know and
that is that there's currently a battle
going on between valor's defense and one
of the victim's grandparents over
seating in The Gallery at trial that's
right according to the Court's
guidelines victims are allowed to sit
and watch the trial but valo's defense
argued in a hearing this week that Kay
and Larry Woodcock the grandparents of
J.J valo would not be considered victims
in this case under Idaho law Witnesses
aren't allowed to sit in and listen to
other Witnesses testimony and there's a
possibility that Kay Woodcock could in
fact be a witness judge Boyce has yet to
make a ruling on this particular matter
let's break it down Brian no death
penalty being tried separately from Chad
I feel like that's got to work in Lori's
favor right yes only split the baby here
for a lack of a better term and sorry
for the important choice of words but no
death penalty makes it a little bit
easier and a little bit harder because
no death penalty means that the stakes
are a little bit lower but it's harder
to negotiate a plea if Lori valadebo
wanted to get one because in the
prosecutor's mind they already reduced
the case uh liability from Death to life
in prison because of a judge's ruling so
they're probably not going to get a good
deal but being tried separately is a
huge win because the end of the day the
jury wants to find the bad person and
here Lori can say that the bad person is
the bad guy her husband because you can
argue why would I kill my children why
would I do this I was maybe forced that
was maybe pressure maybe there's some
sort of coercion maybe my mental health
issues were overcome by this guy go get
him not me it could work to her favor
well Terry Lori valo wants to keep the
grandparents from viewing the trial
because they may be called as Witnesses
do you think that should be allowed in I
think that she should be able to sit
both the grandparents should be able to
sit in there they are victims they are
family and what valo is arguing is no
they're not technically grandmother and
grandfather but they raise the children
as if they were their own now
technically Kay may be called as a
witness that's what we have heard but I
do think that there can be some sort of
compromise here where she's allowed to
sit in most of the trial but then for
portions where there might be some issue
she cannot sit there and I do think that
it's a good rule not to have witnesses
be in the courtroom because they could
change their testimony and that's
exactly why the judge did rule that they
shouldn't be there but these are really
definitely family members they raise
them as such and look while there are no
cameras allowed in that courtroom here
at long crime we are going to do our
best to bring you updates on this trial
because we have been following it since
the very very beginning and we're
finishing off this week in Kenosha
Wisconsin where Alan Brown was convicted
on all charges Thursday for shooting a
canine Officer while running from police
in October of 2021 Wisconsin Wisconsin
officers were notified that brown was in
a stolen vehicle heading in their
Direction he was suspected of two
separate homicides in Chicago that very
same day Kenosha police caught up with
brown at a gas station and got out of
the car to run body camera footage
captures the moment that Deputy Terry
Tift Unleashed canine Rigs and rigs
caught up with brown and tackled him in
mere seconds but was shot at Point Blank
Range in the top of the head now
fortunately canine rigs survive with
only a bruised skull and he returned to
the force just weeks later as for brown
the jury took less than an hour to find
him guilty on endangerment weapons
possession police evasion and animal
cruelty charges he faces more than 70
years on the Wisconsin charges alone at
his sentencing in late may but here is
where things could get a little tricky
in Wisconsin you have 20 days to file an
appeal after a conviction and based on
the performance of Brown's defense
attorney he could have some grounds
Brown was represented by public defender
Addison coon and he gave a very brief
opening statement for his client and
remained relatively quiet throughout the
trial so quiet it points it kind of
looked like he was falling asleep the
defense called No Witnesses and brown
decided not to testify on his own behalf
but the key moments that could help
Brown appeal happen during the party's
discussions of jury instructions check
it out
he went to talk to the defendant in the
hospital
and he's an investigator and he did say
that he did Miranda warnings
but there was a conversation that took
place prior to that that I have a
problem with because we never had any
sort of hearing if there's a challenge
and there never was
it's automatic any objections to reading
uh evidence no
any objections to reading circumstantial
evidence no any objection to reading
information not evidence no
no any objection to weight of the
evidence no jurors knowledge no exhibits
no transcripts not available for
deliberations no
police reports no expert opinion
testimony General
I guess I I don't know did we qualify
anyone as an expert in the case I think
we had to doctor in crime lab and a
crime lab I would consider those experts
because they gave opinions that's fine
you know Terry Brown's still facing
possible charges in Illinois what
happens next for him well technically
technically for his sentencing he may or
may not appeal the case but either way
we know Illinois is going to try to get
him back the charges that he's facing
there are far more serious than the
charges he faced in Wisconsin and he has
so many years that he could serve in
Wisconsin for Illinois they say he
killed two people basically it is on
video so I think it's not going to be
that difficult to show and prove that he
absolutely Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
killed these two people in the
connection with this carjacking so I
believe Wisconsin and Illinois will
absolutely cooperate they'll probably
extradite him back to Illinois so he can
face those charges and then we'll see
what happens this individual is very
dangerous when he was in jail actually
in Wisconsin he headbutted one of the
guards and he had to actually go get
medical help for that so this individual
will do anything to try to escape and to
try to you know be free and he clearly
is a dangerous individual Brian it's not
just sleeping in court with this lawyer
I mean is there more of a case for
ineffective assistance of counsel now
based on what you saw yeah Jesse I hope
that I'm wrong I'm hoping that with the
clips that we're seeing the the portions
that we read and seeing about this case
is
is not accurate of the full picture of
what this public defender did because if
it is in fact true that there was not a
hearing based on pre-merandi statements
there wasn't a pushback on trying to
limit the testimony that came in there
wasn't a a verification that these
experts were qualified if you're guilty
you're guilty that's fine go to jail
that's who you belong but if due process
wasn't given if the sixth amendment
wasn't upheld if the defense wasn't
zealous as everyone is supposed to get
don't be a public defender go do another
job this is not the job for you because
regardless of what the accusations are
for a person they deserve zealous
advocacy and if this person did not do
the job that I signed up for for so many
years don't do it don't stand in line
with me stand somewhere else I think
very well said Brian I hope you're wrong
too about him Brian Terry thank you so
much everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we're going to see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
thank you